this is my proudest moment I've been
dreaming of becoming the top female
swimmer for one year but getting here
wasn't easy
[Applause]
[Music]
I first learned how to swim when I was
seven years old at Boy Scout camp what
might surprise you is is actually a
really slow swimmer at first and stayed
a really slow swimmer through the first
couple years of my collegiate career
then I turned 23 and all of a sudden I'm
the best swimmer in the women's division
and I can't track exactly what changed
I guess I'm just a late bloomer because
swimming's been such a big part of my
life for so long it's where my happiness
comes from it's it's hard to believe
that this is like real that Leah Thomas
becoming being a male Collegiate swimmer
yeah becoming a female swimmer is real
yeah it how is this real how is this not
just like a [ __ ] parody of real life
like we're watching we should be
watching a movie I don't know it's I get
it's a little more satirical because he
has a beard and big ass muscles but it's
it's the same exact thing at the end of
the day yeah it's the same thing at the
end of the day I couldn't agree more you
can't have happiness without penis
I've never noticed that before with
being the best it's something you always
get haters like I don't understand what
this controversy is all about
I guess people just don't like it when
they see a woman succeeding I compete in
three different strokes freestyle the
butterfly and the backstroke you got to
be in the pool for hours each day that's
the only way to become the best
I guess I must have drank a lot of water
on that lap yeah it's not all easy some
of the other ladies don't feel
comfortable being in the same locker
room as me I'm appalled I just don't
understand why like is this because I
identify as black these racist women
around here or maybe they're just
intimidating I wonder if you'll be able
to identify as different races
eventually uh there was that woman
Rachel when I last say Rachel dalzal
we'll have to maybe we can do some
reactions to her sometimes so a few
years ago she was uh a leader at a um
NAACP chapter in I want to say
Washington State it doesn't really
matter does it and she was a you know a
black woman very outspoken very in the
public eye very in the black community
and it turned out she was white as white
gets she her whole life blonde hair
blue-eyed she went and got her hair
redone so it was like kinkier and she
just and she just pretended to be a
light-skinned black woman and it became
a national controversy and she lost her
job so imagine being you know black
community activists you spend your
entire life devoted your title
profession devoted to the NAACP and
you're sitting next to another black
woman who really says she feels your
pain she feels it all she understands
she gets this community and she's on
your team and then you turn out she's a
little blonde-haired blue-eyed Aryan
[ __ ] the whole time it's crazy so it
did happen already and she was
ostracized and pushed to the side so now
kind of feeling for her because I I
watched uh there's a documentary about
her and she's a little crazy I felt bad
for her at the end of it but now she's
got now here she's got to be sitting
there watching Leah Thomas and be like
how come I got shoved to the side yeah
all I did was pretend my skin color was
a little darker than it is it's funny
this guy's like way overstepping that
and she was doing good for the black
community like she was at least doing
good this guy's actually hurting women
in my opinion interesting by my sensual
femininity I mean you know how girls can
be
jealous
swimming brings out the Divine goddess
in me hey get out of the pool that's for
ladies only some of my competitors are
angry that I tested positive for having
XY chromosomes and I don't know how they
got there but I had like a tainted
supplement or something but really I
think my competitors are just sore
losers like hey ladies I beat you by 11
minutes fair and square so get over it
to me swimming is really an art form
an art form that requires a lot of upper
body strength like the more of it you
have the more of an advantage you have
women can most certainly get other women
pregnant I've done it what do you have
to say about your teammates wanting you
off the team yeah my sore loser teammate
and now they're saying men or when men
can get pregnant like they're they're
trying to go so backwards that they're
gonna go out and teach that men can get
pregnant too in schools do we teach that
you can have two to three eyes or do we
teach that you have two eyes it's maybe
they should get in the pool and train
more the reason why I win all the time
is because I'm more dedicated to my
training we talked to your coach and he
said that your teammates spend the exact
same amount of time training in the pool
as you
well I work out with weights too maybe
they should try it it really helps you
coach says they're on the exact same
weightlifting routine as you but he said
you bench pressed four and a half times
more weight than the second strongest
athlete do you have any idea why that is
well I just don't identify the weights
as very heavy it's pretty simple it
feels so good to Come Away with a
championship and I want to congratulate
second place for being within nine
minutes of me and I want to thank my
sponsors for always having my back
manscaping dollar beard club and Alpha
jock straps now that I'm the top female
swimmer what's next for me well I don't
feel like I'm 22 anymore so I think
children's Sports is next probably
peewee football I'm actually 10 years
old now even more than my swimming
success what I'm most proud if you stand
for nothing you tolerate anything or if
you tolerate anything you stand for
nothing I meant to say so if we start
with this [ __ ] like I said liberal would
say the same thing I mean just use it to
their advantage yeah but this started
with with gay people back in like
seventh and eighth grade I remember that
back then the whole agenda was just let
gay people be gay who cares everyone's
like yeah I mean who who gives a [ __ ] if
you want to go and talk to dudes does
anybody care no and then slowly it just
kept pushing and pushing and inching and
inching and inching and here we are now
with men winning women's sports see I
disagree what do you disagree with there
though because that's what it was it
started with just LGB was it not just
like LGBT or just LGB at first and then
it slowly went to lgbtq lgbtq plus and
then now they have like the African flag
mixed in with the with the lgbtq flag
it's like holding on to each other but I
I agree in general in the slippery slope
uh philosophy if you let one thing
happen you know it's either if you give
them uh you give them an inch they take
the whole yard
I disagree that this is anything at all
like gay people be gay people I'm saying
that's where it started because that
there was literally no
um no
effect on anybody else except hardcore
this this group of Hardcore Christians
who insist that that you know they read
the Bible literally and being gay Tate
does that and he gets on my nerves with
it the Bible says it's bad right no no
listen so that so there was no there was
there was only those people who were
personally offended by gays this is a
different situation because I feel like
this is unrelated because these people
this started with hey let let Sheila
whose real name is Frank go to the
bathroom just go to the bathroom first
that's what just join us and we're all
just going to pretend that Frankie
Sheila and it's fine okay we're all
gonna be polite that's where that
started it enough it to me this is
unrelated from the gays and I want to
continually separate this from the case
because I don't want the gays having any
shadow of this [ __ ] on them well
that's what they've done they've put it
all under the same umbrella but we have
to be the ones to separate it and
understand that the Gaze over here are
not responsible for this [ __ ] no I
know and I'm not saying there I'm just
saying that's where it all started I'm
saying that was like the first push
because it's all still under the same
umbrella so that was like the first
opening of the umbrella that you don't
see my point and then from there like
you said you just have to acknowledge
them as a person you have to just do all
this [ __ ] now you have to let them in
the bathrooms now we need to make three
bathrooms for more inclusivity now they
want to play in sports it's basically
every single let there be like at the
Rando [ __ ] Rando bathroom
yeah just call it randos but I don't
want dudes
or ladies
the thing is underneath in the in the
restroom with me I know the thing is
nobody cares if these people are trans
or whatever it's just the way that they
shove it down your throat in school they
try to change the entire world view and
then you have men playing in women's
sports like now you just crossed the
line now it's like all right we keep
going with this logic what's next they
have men in women's prisons too so there
are cases all around the country well
there's rape and there's also consensual
sex and in many cases it's leading to
pregnant pregnant inmates in FEMA in
women's prisons because they have an
actual dude with a schlong walking
around women's prison and taking showers
with them and sleeping with them like
you know bunking in the same rooms no no
you're going in the Men's prison you can
you can put on makeup all day long deal
with it they may like it all right let's
keep it on motive is what I'm doing for
women's rights it's kind of like if
you've ever seen an injured deer on the
side of the road that's just been hit by
a car and your heart just just wants to
help this wounded animal
well
I'm the one that hit the deer I watch
his stuff but I know
I know you'd be like you see two minutes
of hours but I like him because he has
fun he has cool products and stuff he
has like cups that have his name and
they say you know liberal tears and and
cute stuff thank you guys for watching
smell you later bye
[Music]
[Music]